- As we've seen in other
videos, this is a map
of the European possessions,
especially the Western European
possessions in much of
the world as we enter
into the 20th century before World War I.
You see significant
possessions by the French
not just in Africa but also in Indochina.
You see the British also
have significant possessions
in Africa, but also in Asia.
Germany, Belgium, Italy also
have imperial possessions.
Now as we go through World War I,
that changes the map of
Europe fairly dramatically
and we talk about that in other videos
but some of the major outcomes,
at least when we're talking
about imperialism is that
the Austro-Hungarian Empire
gets broken up, changing
the map of Eastern Europe,
the Ottoman Empire gets broken up,
with much of the Middle
East now under control
by the British or French
and of course Russian exits
World War I having had the
Bolshevik Revolution in 1917
and is now the Soviet Union.
As we get into the period after
World War I, we start to see
momentum gather in terms
of independence movements,
in terms of this imperial
structure breaking down.
In 1922, Egypt becomes
independent of the United Kingdom.
Iraq, which was part of the
Ottoman Empire for centuries
was put under British
control after World War I
and in 1932, it gets its independence.
Then we enter into World War
II, which is an incredibly
traumatic time, not just for
Europe but for the world.
And as we exit out of World War II,
we see further momentum
being gained for the various
anti-colonial independence movements.
Indonesia, which was
originally a Dutch colony
but during World War II, gets
under the control of Japan
as part of its imperial possessions,
but as we get into August of
1945, the Japanese are bombed
at Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
effectively ending World War II
and the Indonesians are able
to claim their independence
nominally now from the Dutch.
Then from 1944 to 1946,
further possessions
that were originally part
of the Ottoman Empire
but after World War I
became under the control
of the French and
British, Syria and Jordan,
gain their independence.
Syria from France and
Jordan from United Kingdom.
And then in 1947, you
have the independence
of the Indian subcontinent.
This is a particularly noteworthy struggle
under the leadership of Mohandas Gandhi,
often known as Mahatma Gandhi,
mahatma meaning great soul.
And it's a peaceful resistance
that's able to get independence.
Now the subcontinent is partitioned
into what will become Pakistan and India.
For the most part, areas
that were majority Muslim
became Pakistan and you can
see this region in the west,
and this region in the
east which would later
get its independence in
1971 and become Bangladesh,
and then for the most part,
regions that had Hindu
majorities became India.
This wasn't a clean partition
because there were some
territories, princely states,
areas where the majority
was not clear that
became under contention.
Kashmir, even to this day,
is a point of contention
between India and Pakistan.
Much of the Indian
subcontinent was very mixed
with some areas being 60% Hindu
or 40% Muslim or vice versa
so that catalyzed one of
the largest migrations
in human history, the number
of people changing borders,
sometimes becoming quite
sectarian and quite bloody.
But even after that, India is still
one of the largest Muslim countries.
The founder of Pakistan is
Muhammad Ali Jinnah and India's
first prime minister and
both of them were active
in the independence movement,
is Jawaharlal Nehru,
who will become famous for
the non-aligned movement,
for newly liberated
countries to not want to side
on either side of the Cold
War and he actually coins
the term third world
which is now associated
with developing countries,
but when it was coined,
it meant, we don't wanna be first world
aligned with the western
capitalist countries,
we don't wanna be second world,
aligned with the communist block,
we wanna be independent
or the third world.
As we get into the late
'40s and early '50s,
we also see an independence
movement in French Indochina.
These countries will eventually
become North Vietnam,
South Vietnam, Laos, and
Cambodia, and a significant figure
here is Ho Chi Minh who will
become a very prominent figure
as the French Indochina
War eventually evolves
into the Vietnam War, bringing
the United States into it
as part of its Cold War
containment strategy.
The 1950s also see significant
independence movements
throughout Africa.
In 1951, Libya gains independence.
From 1956 to 1958, Tunisia,
Morocco, Ghana, Guinea,
all gain independence.
Of particular note is Ghana,
originally called Gold Coast.
The first president and prime
minister is Kwame Nkrumah
and he's known as one of the founders
of the Organization of African Unity
and he wanted to see where a
world where as these African
countries became
independent, they unified,
seeing that Africa would
have much more power
as a unified entity than
as a fragmented one.
And so he was a major promoter
of the idea of pan-Africanism.
Now the independence
movements only accelerated
as we go into the 1960s.
1960 in particular was a year
of many independence movements
but you can see here, most
of Africa was independent
as we exit the 1960s.
In blue here, listed the
French colonies that gained
independence in this time period.
In this salmon color,
the British colonies,
and in yellow, the Belgian colonies.
There would continue to be
change over the next few decades
but the world starts to look very similar
to the world as we recognize it today.
Now I'll leave you with a
speech that Jawaharlal Nehru
made in Washington DC in 1956,
which highlights his
desire for nonalignment.
"The preservation of peace
forms the central aim
"of India's policy.
"It is in the pursuit of this
policy that we have chosen
"the path of nonalignment in any military
"or like pact of alliance.
"Nonalignment does not mean
passivity of mind or action,
"lack of faith or conviction,
it does not mean submission
"to what we consider evil.
"It is a positive and dynamic approach
"to such problems that confront us.
"We believe that each country
has not only the right
"to freedom but also to decide
"its own policy and way of life."
And this is a big deal because remember,
he's giving this speech in
Washington DC which would love
him to clearly align
with the western block,
with the capitalist countries
led by the United States
but after working so hard
for their independence,
many of these nations, like
India, were not eager to lose
their autonomy and realign
with more powerful countries.
To close out this video, I'll
leave you with an interesting
question or a series of
interesting questions.
Why do we see a good chunk of
the world become independent
in the second half of the 20th century?
Was it that the imperial
countries no longer had the energy
or the power or the will
to control these colonies?
Was it something happened
in the psychology
of their peoples, they just
went through a traumatic war,
and they realized that
they weren't interested
in controlling the
destiny of other people?
Was it due to the efficacy
of some of these independence
struggles, like the nonviolence
movement led by Gandhi?
Or maybe some of the more
violent independence struggles
like what we saw in
Algeria against the French.
But needless to say, the
world fundamentally changed
in this time period.
When we were entering
into the 20th century,
we had an imperial world,
especially controlled
by the Western European powers.
After two traumatic wars,
imperialism comes to an end
and we see the world as we know it today.